les avantages injustifiés dont
bénéficient certaines catégories le site
enfin dans ce même conseil une
communication du ministre d'éducation
alain savary sur la réforme de
l'enseignement supérieur les grandes
orientations et les premières réactions
des étudiants par dominique laurie
démocratiser l'université et donner aux
étudiants une solide formation
professionnelle tels sont les objectifs
de la réforme de l'enseignement
supérieur qui sera discuté au parlement
au printemps 80 toi plus qu'un
bouleversement
c'est une rénovation des études en
fonction des réalités économiques
d'aujourd'hui au quartier latin
les premières réactions des étudiants
semblent dans l'ensemble favorables on
est quand même vision étudier dans ce
pays on est un million à avoir un
diplôme a cherché à avoir un diplôme
pour avoir ensuite un métier dans les
meilleures conditions possibles
c'est une partie importante de la
population qui avait besoin de voir les
choses changer pour elle pour que c'est
l'aspiration avoir le meilleur diplôme
possibles puissent être aujourd'hui
satisfaite et je pense que c'est un peu
ce que les étudiants attendent de la
nouvelle réforme qui va être leur est
proposé vous pensez que ces deux
réformes d'un petit peu amélioré la
situation des étudiants
j'espère que à l'améliorer j'espère
principale mesure le premier 6 sera
profondément réorganisé priorité à
l'orientation et à la connaissance des
débouchés l'informatique est une langue
étrangère deviennent des disciplines
obligatoires
enfin formation pluridisciplinaire avec
une dominante professionnels
quand on arrive à l'université c'est
pour acquérir des connaissances c'est
aussi et surtout pour avoir un métier et
la question c'est que dès la première
année
il ya nécessité d'avoir une connaissance
du milieu professionnel dans son
ensemble en pas de sélection à l'entrée
de l'université mais une refonte des
diplômes d'études universitaires
générales le fameux dogues dans le
second cycle priorité à la formation
professionnelle afin de permettre aux
étudiants de trouver rapidement des
emplois correspondant à leurs
qualifications
là une interrogation si la
professionnalisation s'est trouvé un
emploi qualifié qui correspondent à nos
études
je pense que tout le monde ne peut
qu'être pour donc pour cela il faut
avoir des diplômes qu'ils soient
effectivement reconnu mais qui est une
une base large qui permette de sortir
avec de l'université avec plusieurs
cordes à son arc
parce que si on est trop liée à une
profession par exemple personne ne peut
demain savoir quel sera le marché de
l'emploi et on pourra pas si on a un
diplôme trop pointu trop poussé sortir
et s'est trouvé un travail dans une
autre branche autre volet important le
rapprochement universités grandes écoles
aujourd'hui complètement séparée pour ce
faire des liens contractuels seront
créées ainsi que des échanges de
personnel enfin ouverture des
universités sur leur environnement par
le renforcement des personnalités
extérieures collectivités locales
secteur économique au conseil des
universités
bref des mesures qui réduiront peut-être
10 des étudiants les inégalités
actuelles
quand on est enfant d'ouvrier ou
d'employé il est pratiquement impossible
d'arriver à l'université c'est pas le
seul problème en première année plus de
la moitié des étudiants qui s'inscrivent
en première année ne vont pas jusqu'au
bout ou pas soit parce qu'ils échouent
aux examens soit encore pire parce
qu'ils avaient avant même les examens
enfin bien souvent dans l'impression que
l'université une formation générale
abstraite mais qui ne nous donne pas un
emploi à la sortie de formation donc
deux au moins pour ces trois raisons il
fallait qu'ils une réforme
pour le ministre de l'éducation
nationale comme pour claude jeantet
l'auteur du projet cette réforme reste
fidèle à l'esprit de la loi de novembre
68 autonomie pluridisciplinarité
participations trois principes dit alain
savary qui ont été bien mal appliquée il
s'agit en fait d'un approfondissement
d'une réelle application de ces lignes
de force